What do you call this miracle oh
me-throud no no it would be mithril.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be my
full Lord of the Rings the Rings of Power episode
4 video there's a whole bunch of Easter eggs and
references so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel I'm doing videos for
all the episodes be sure to subscribe to get them
and careful for spoilers for the episode if you
haven't seen it yet we'll start at the beginning
and work our way through shot by shot talking
about Easter eggs and WTF moments as we go along
starting with the episode title it was titled
The Great Wave which is a direct reference to
the eventual downfall of numenor it was literally
sunk into the ocean by the one true God of The
Lord of the Rings Universe a louvitar after
the new minorians try to invade the continent
of valinor on the advice of Sauron bad advice
obviously after convincing most of them that
they could achieve true immortality like the elves
if they served his master morgoth and conquered
valinor and we literally see that occur during
the episode like they touched the palantir and
see a vision of the future the downfall of numenor
and even though Galadriel tries to tell Muriel not
all the visions that you see in the palantir come
to pass this one will definitely come to pass we
know because it's in the books like they're not
going to change that they're just trying to show
us the circumstances that eventually led to that
and that's basically what a lot of this episode is
dedicated to like showing you what's happening
in numenor that eventually causes the downfall
there's also a lot of references to the sinking
of balerion the actual part of the Middle Earth
continent that sank into the ocean during the
war of Wrath so there's a lot of sinking going
on during the episode the whole thing with the
downfall of numenor though is that if you remember
in earlier episodes they kind of referenced the
origin of the Island the island itself was a gift
to the original numenoreans for their service
during the war of Wrath in The Valor basically
Rose it directly out of the ocean like it didn't
exist before the Valor gave it to them so during
the downfall of numenor when they tried to invade
valinor they basically took their gift back like
they just pulled it back into the ocean there
were also a lot of references to the faithful
especially at the end of the episode where they
referenced the new minorians that survived the
downfall like asilder and his family who went to
Middle Earth and later created Gondor and a lot of
the other structures that that you see during
the events of the movies also fun Easter egg
too like the palantir obviously a big deal during
this episode revealing it there were seven seeing
Stones the reason why Saruman has one later in
the timeline during the third age is because
the faithful amongst the new minorians rescued
all seven of them and brought them to Middle
Earth with them when they created Gondor so in the
episode when Muriel says all the stones have been
lost except for this one they're lost on a numenor
like all the stones are still on numenor with the
exception of the master stone which is still back
in valinor they originally created by fandor and
then given to the numenoreans as a gift fan or
was the elf that created the silmarils that they
referenced in episode 1 that hammer is the hammer
of fan or that he used to create the summer ills
he also probably used it to create the palantir
as well but the opening scene of the episode is
Muriel in the palace performing a ceremony with a
recently newborn children on the island when they
feel the island quake in the white tree sheds its
petals and she basically has a nightmare of the
downfall itself which we see again later in the
episode when Galadriel touches the the palantir in
the next scene is actually kind of ironic because
it's the person who Hal brand was fighting with in
last week's episode that got him thrown in prison
and he's talking about Galadriel Whispering poison
in their Queen's ear which is exactly what Sauron
winds up doing later to pharazon specifically
that leads to the eventual downfall of numenor
itself in the whole early part of the episode
here is dedicated to showing you the anti-valor
element growing stronger on the island in Fair
Zone building his influence in that base like
basically gives them a make numenor great kind
of speech which is a stark contrast to the end
of the episode when Muriel says that they're
actually going to send an expeditionary Force to
actually help Galadriel to Middle Earth and that
will become the faithful the people that survive
the downfall the people who are still faithful to
the Valar and the elves during the episode they're
a couple times too when isilder says oh I won't
be able to go west now because I've been kicked
out of the sea guard turns out that's actually
pretty smart move don't want to go west because
the West is the continent of valinor you want
to stay as far away from valinor as possible when
pharazon starts was talking about the adane they
were one of the first factions of humans created
on the planet the ones who initially settled in
beleriand the land that was sunk ironically again
so like we talk about sinking places in The Lord
of the Rings universe numenor and beleriand both
wound up on the bottom of the ocean so it was
sort of an ironic history repeats itself kind of
situation it's just that the circumstances of them
sinking both of these different places were very
different when he mentions are armenelos that's
the name of the main city in the port area here
of new there's smaller cities and settlements all
over the island like alendil comes from one of the
other settlements not the main city when he says
Elven hands will never take numenor's Helm that's
true technically because it's going to sink to the
bottom of the ocean elves don't want to have
anything to do with it and no I don't believe
that he's secretly Sauron in disguise like Sauron
eventually let himself be captured by numenor in
the books and then started whispering in his ear
others at court promising them immortality if they
turn towards morgoth invaded valinor played their
anti-valar sentiment against them basically this
is also a funny reference to this with how
brand speech later in the episode 2 playing
people's fears against them during this part of
the episode you could also make the joke that
Sauron is secretly all the toxic friends we made
along the way like eventually I do think that we
will see a physical Sauron walking around on the
show but until then this growing Shadow is sort
of covering everything in a more metaphorical
kind of way like the darkness in men's Hearts
is growing in part of that is Sauron working his
magic in the background in the shadows later in
the episode when the man mentions melatarma when
he's offering isilder's sister the wine that's
their sacred Mountain at the center of numenor
when Galadriel is telling Muriel about sauron's
plan for Mordor in his special Mark she jokes
that alendel is secretly a runic Emperor that's
both a joke about him eventually becoming a king
of Gondor when they build it near Mordor and ruin
the actual location in Middle Earth it's on
mordor's eastern border we've seen a few of
their people who sided with Sauron during the war
of the Ring later in the timeline but we haven't
actually seen a lot of that place like it's kind
of this big area that you haven't explored forward
a lot up so we might actually see some of roon
during the events of the show when she tries to
win Muriel over and she says that numenor has
chosen another path that's another reference to
the downfall of numenor and the people who follow
Sauron eventually but when Galadriel responds not
all of numenor she's talking about alendil in the
faithful the group of people at the end of the
episode who all raised their hand and say oh we'll
go to Middle Earth we'll fight turns out pretty
smart decision for them and when she gets herself
thrown in prison she and Hal brand Bond a little
bit more like they're growing a little bit closer
even the Galadriel still doesn't really like him
that much and then even though I no longer think
that Hal brand is secretly Sauron or anything like
that in Disguise his speech does reference Sauron
heavily he says using what her enemy fears against
them by offering them a means of mastering it
that's basically what Sauron does to cause the
downfall of numenor exploit all the numenorians
fear of death pharah's own particularly by
offering them immortality which really wasn't his
to offer anyway it's the same tactic that he uses
against the elves and Keller brimbor into creating
the actual rings of of power offering them a
solution to the problem that they're looking to
solve preserve all of their Realms which is kind
of one of the side effects of the Rings of power
preserving things the sealger winds up getting
kicked out of the sea guard with his friends who
also become part of the faithful at the end of
the episode they just want to show you what it is
that causes him to eventually leave numenor all
the Whispers that he hears saying his name I think
are just a reference to him being faithful to the
elves to the Valar they could also be a reference
to his dead mother too there's so much going on in
the background of every single sentence that they
say to each other in this episode that in order
to catch it all you'd have to pause and read an
entire chapter of a book just to see everything
that they're talking about one of his friends that
gets kicked out with him here is named valando he
has the same name as one of assilder's sons later
in the timeline of the books who becomes one of
the kings of men so either names his son after his
friend to honor him or they just change the plot
a little bit and his friend eventually winds up
becoming one of the kings of men back in the orc
camp they finally revealed joseph mawle's at our
character irondir meets him he's the elf that's
played by joseph mawle everybody remembers him
as benjen from Game of Thrones his Gauntlet at
hands the armor that we see is probably the ones
that we saw in the posters that they released
before the series came out you notice how dark
his skin looks compared to other elves we call
him a dark Fallen elf his skin literally looks
like it's darker all the scarring on his face
of the wounds are probably left over from the war
of Wrath itself and he's got this weird connection
with the Orcs we find out that the Orcs refer to
him as their father which I think is just loaded
with all kinds of meaning because he stops just
short of explaining the true origin of the Orcs
And I think that's what's going on here like
during the episode when he's talking to Iran
deer he says it'd take him forever to explain the
truth of the story if you knew the real story it
would make your head spin basically and I think
what he's referring to is the events that led to
the creation of the original Orcs the Orcs were
originally elves from a place called kuivinen I
think I'm pronouncing that correctly who morgoth
found before the elves were able to answer the a
call of the Valar and become the noldor elves like
when a louvitar created the elves originally there
were a couple different tribes and they were all
just kind of sitting around eventually the rest
of the Valar found them and called them to valinor
and the ones that answered the call are referred
to as the noldor elves which Galadriel descends
from but morgoth found the original elves before
the other Valar did and was able to steal some of
them and take them to his original Fortress which
I believe is supposed to be the Fortress the
Galadriel finds at the beginning of episode 1
with the forge and the orc melted into the wall so
that could have also been the place where morgoth
turned those original elves into the original
Orcs it may be one of the reasons why these Orcs
call Adar father is because he was part of morgas
forces with Sauron in creating those original Orcs
so he's kind of like their father so to speak or
maybe he was directly related by blood to some of
the elves that were turned into orcs so like these
orcs are literally his descendant but either way
Adar seems like he is part of that original group
that fought with morgoth during the war of Wrath
because he has this whole conversation with
Arondir about beleriand that original place
that sank into the ocean during the war of Wrath
irondir was born there later in the timeline but
it sounds like Adar actually visited that place
a long time ago way before that the river he
references specifically might be sirion that's
the main river running south to North through
beleriand the other big thing going on during
the episode here with the Orcs too is they try
to show you some of the actual culture of the Orcs
whereas previously the way they've been depicted
in the Peter Jackson movies in in a lot of the
other media is just being completely chaotic
like they've shown the Orcs as having some loose
military structure but like you don't see a lot
of actual culture within their race when he
references the creation of a new world that's
morgoth's original Mission to reshape the world
into his vision also side note he and the other
Valar weren't capable of creating new life forms
or new places only a illuvitar could do that like
only the one true God could actually create brand
new things even though the Valar are crazy Cosmic
level powerful beings they can only reshape what's
already existed which is why he had to originally
turn those original elves into Orcs instead of
just magicing up brand new Orcs out of nothing
add our references this later too when he says
that he's no god yet only the gods can do things
like that and as far as I know he's not supposed
to be Sauron like he could wind up turning into
like the Mouth of Sauron or like some crazy twist
with a huge character later in the movies that we
don't know that much about but I don't think
he's literally meant to be a version of Sauron
in Disguise he's not a character from the books
he might be based on a character from the books
but within the context of the show he's just
like a fallen elf that winds up serving the Orcs
morgoth And Sauron but they kind of tease him
telling the rest of his story and I think that
gets into the original creation of the Orcs and
that'll explain why he is a fallen elf like why
he started serving morgoth and how he's related
to the Orcs themselves we also find out that one
of his big missions right now is to get Theo's
sword the special sword that we actually find out
was created directly by morgoth infused with all
this power it is like the special one off thing
it's not like a sword that was given to anybody
that served morgoth and Sauron during the war of
Wrath he also wants the rest of the southlanders
to swear fealty to his army and give them the rest
of these lands so they can finish turning them
into what will become Mordor back in a region
elrond and celebrimbor watched the dwarves help
them create the new tower Forge is probably going
to take most of the season to finish that like we
might get a big teaser at the end of season one
for that he mentions elrond's father Ira Randall
who was half clven himself the statue in the Bay
of numenor is of him like he's got the silmaril in
his forehead here he explains his backstory how he
was the first mortal to set foot on valinor
he got in big trouble for that too but he's
also the one who convinced the Valar to join the
war of Wrath against morgoth there was kind of a
reference to him during the prologue too when you
see the dragons and the Eagles fighting he helped
take down morgoth's biggest dragon and at the end
of that the Valar made it so that his ship could
actually fly and he would sail across the heavens
with the silmaril sort of watching over because
it was meant to be sort of a punishment but also
kind of a blessing in disguise like The Valor had
to punish him for breaking the van on entering
valinor but they also wanted to reward him so
their compromise was to allow him to live out the
rest of time basically sailing through the sky
with a silmarill in his ship basically becoming
the star of irandel they referenced that in a
previous episode too that star is the star symbol
that you see all over the numenor island all over
their stuff all over the place is the same star in
the background of the room of the palantir elrond
talks about the star later in the episode looking
up at the heavens looking at it thinking if his
father is watching down on him wondering whether
or not he's led a good life in his father's eyes
this is like a whole trilogy of movies that
you could do about the first stage and what
happens with elrond's father in the war of Wrath
all that stuff you could do like a completely
separate series too I'm sure at some point either
Amazon or somebody else is going to either make a
bunch of movies about it or some other Series this
out of the whole storyline with the mithril and
the balrog when Keller brimbor says I think the
dwarves are hiding something from me you notice
that the tune that elrond uses to enter this
place is the same tune that Duran's children were
singing in his house when he mentions punishment
for breaking his oath the mountain dooming him
and his kin forever that's also a sly reference to
the doom of the dwarves and how they unwillingly
caused the balrog to attack them in khazad dum
the downfall of their race is also similar to the
downfall of numenor in this way like ultimately
both races greed cause their downfall most of this
whole mithril Dwarven storyline during the episode
is referencing that in what will eventually happen
with the balrog like you feel the ground Quake
you hear some roars in the background like oh
that is definitely the balrog waking up the bat
rock is actually featured in the trailer so at
some point during the series we'll see a version
of it the way during the fourth explains it in the
episode though his father is heavily restricting
their mining out of caution it sounds like his
father will eventually die during the events of
the series either season 1 season 2 during the
fourth will become king and then he'll push them
to continue over mining the area and that will
wind up waking the balrog up like there's this
whole thing with durin IV being super aggressive
about mining for mithril new age for our people
lead us to to great new things also leading them
to a big fat balrog cool foreshadowing moment
too when he gives him the mithril sample as a
token of their friendship the doors of Duran are
made with mithral by Keller brimbor later in the
timeline that also becomes a symbol of the door's
larger friendship with the elves at this time
Lord of moria speaking friend we check back
in with isilder's sister she's a draftsman
meaning she creates plans for buildings unless
he's drawing a plan for the doors here which I
think is also meant to be a sly foreshadowing
for the future creation of Gondor like all the
new minorian structures that later in the timeline
exist in Middle Earth but also for the creation of
the doors of durin even though the new minorians
didn't create those doors that was calabrimbor
that created those but what they might be doing
with his sister because she's not a character
from the books as they could be setting her up
as a person who designs a lot of plans that they
used in the creation of Gondor and a lot of these
structures when a sealder meets with his sister
it sounds like the music they play was a little
bit like the Lord of the Rings movie music like
they're kind of later referencing what happens
with Aragorn later also I believe the painting
on the wall above them is from the war of Wrath
with them fighting borgos monster both the humans
and the elves in Alliance just another reference
to the faithful the new minorians who still do
believe in their alliance with the elves in the
Valar the sea monster also kind of looks like
the same one that Galadriel and halbrand just
escaped recently as well then they have the
whole scene with the palantir I explained that
earlier in the video how basically eventually
a sealder and the other faithful will find the
rest of them and take them to Middle Earth with
them when they eventually migrate before the Duma
numenor and a lot of this part of the episode is
meant to be foreshadowing for Muriel listening to
the portents the white tree shedding its petals
which is a sign the evil is coming like danger
is near the funny thing about the pedal shedding
too is they literally shed in the direction of
Galadriel like the whole island and they all
just kind of blow in her Direction like oh yeah
you should probably be listening to what gladriel
said which caused her to allow the faithful like
a group of numenoreans to go with her to fight
on Middle Earth when we check back in with Theo
he gets saved by Iran deer obviously the reason
why the Orcs don't follow them into the clearing
out of the woods is because they're so sensitive
to light they're kind of like vampires in that
way and that they have to live underground like
the sunlight Burns their skin literally we
learn a little bit about how the doors also
uncover new veins and minerals when disa is
seeing this special ceremony here she says they
were trying to pray to the mountain to save the
miners but they also referenced this in earlier
episodes where she talks about being one of the
people that helps them find new veins like she
talks metaphorically so to speak to the mountain
but a lot of it has to do with these songs that
she sings and I think a lot of that gets into the
Sonic vibrations in the notes of her actual song
she makes it sound kind of magical so there
might be like a little bit of magic involved
because magic obviously does exist in The Lord
of the Rings universe but I think some of it
is also practical with the Sonic vibrations too
later when during the fourth is talking to his
father being suspicious that something larger as
a foot with the elves the plan to create the forge
that's just another reference to the eventual
creation of the Rings of power and what Sauron
is doing and then aside from like the palantir
and a lot of the other cool history one of the
best moments of the episode I thought was when we
get the prophecy reveal about sauron's return and
we find out about the origin of the magic sword
that Theo's been wielding The Old Man reveals that
the sword previously belonged to him and it just
belonged to one of his ancestors like he himself
was not alive to serve morgoth during the war of
Wrath because the life expectancy for the humans
living in the Southlands was closer to like 90
years so it would have been one of his Grand
fathers or another ancestor earlier in his life
that would have gained possession of the sword
but the way that Adar talks about The Sword and
the other Orcs sounds like it didn't originally
belong to a human like it either belonged to one
of the original human kings that served morgoth
or belonged to morgoth or Sauron himself which
is why it sounds like either Theo or his father
might wind up becoming the witch king of angmar
or one of the other kings of men that become the
nazuel like the ones that wield the rings of
power the power the old man refers to in the
sword is Sauron and morgoth's power when he says
it was fashioned by his master's own hand he means
the sword was created by sauron's Master morgoth
himself which is probably another reference to
the special Forge in his Fortress that Galadriel
found the sword was also probably forged on that
altar when he says beautiful servant that's
a reference to Sauron in his true form this
is what he looks like this is a deleted scene
from Lord of the Rings Return of the King this
is what he looked like when he wasn't wearing the
armor but the reason why he looks so beautiful is
because they're like these Angelic beings the old
man also references me Meteor Man saying that that
was a sign that Sauron's return was near but not
that Meteor Man was Sauron himself specifically
I think that the mystery man is meant to be one
of the Wizards we also find out that people who
wield the sword are branded by it with the same
Mark of Sauron on their arms so either let me
know in the comments because this sword seems
like it belonged to Sauron specifically or to
Morgoth and maybe it was given to the original
King of the Southlands here there's this whole
idea of Hal Bran's line of Kings sort of like the
dark Twist on Aragorn's character in his line of
Kings separately that come from a seal dirt but do
you think that Theo or his father wind up becoming
one of the Nazgul or the witch king of angmar
but then at the end of the episode like I said
they have the white tree shedding its petals as
galadriel's leaving letting Muriel know that she
needs to pay attention to Galadriel because the
white tree only sheds its petals when it senses
danger is near and it's happening literally in
the direction of Galadriel like the petals are
flowing to Galadriel in her whole speech at the
end of the episode is a big call to action for
the people on newmanor to pick a side become the
part of the faithful or stay in the people that
stay the that don't raise their hand are probably
the ones that are eventually turned by Sauron so
if you spotted any other references in the episode
that I didn't talk about in the video just write
down below in the comments there's like a billion
things that happened in this episode so you could
watch it like 10 times and find brand new stuff
hopefully we don't have to wait too long before we
find out adar's real connection with the Orcs but
I explained what I think his history is supposed
to be earlier in the video my full episode 5 video
will post next Friday after they release it in
my house the Dragon episode 5 video will post
Sunday there's a bunch of other stuff happening
too Star Wars and or episodes are starting next
week too they'll be the first three episodes it
is supposed to be fire so it sounds like it's
going to be really cool my episode videos for
that series will post on Wednesdays it'll be a
Wednesday show everyone click here for my house
of the Dragon episode 5 trailer video and click
here for all my other Lord of the Rings episode
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!